[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live i'm on podcast
watchinggaming.net
and who is this fine gentleman we have
in the realm of pax today uh my name is
rob i'm a producer on dive by the blade
made by triple h hill interactive and
published by quality nice now dying by
the blade i will say this is one of the
titles that we won't pass and we said
what is this because this looks amazing
thank you so fighting game tradition of
the lords come from this tell us about
the fighting in this game the style what
was the inspiration to make dive out of
blade so the inspiration to die for the
blade and really the
the core of that by the blade is keeping
it skill based
you know
there are fighting games that can
not descend into button matching but
maybe where skill isn't quite as
important
it's not quite as prioritized as as we
would like so dive by the blade it's all
about being better than your opponent
knowing the weapons inside out okay the
weapons are really what's key to this
game so you you know you see you've got
characters there we've got nakamura
we've got yoshi's the star of our single
player campaign
now i'm seeing yoshi dual blade sword
style sure right and then we got
nakamura traditional samurai
like is this going to be a thing where a
lot of the characters have individual
style types per weapon and is it
exclusively bladed combat as well it's
exclusively bladed combat but the
weapons work with any character
so
some characters do have a preference
perhaps like yoshi and the katana
match made in heaven but any character
can use any weapon if you are good
enough you can beat anybody with any
character in any way in any weapon and
now let's break down from a technical
standpoint he said he's a skill-based
fighter sure so for the technical
standpoint i'm seeing the meetings i'm
seeing resolve i'm seeing the circle
over here what what are these meters
representing so this here this is
showing your stance
so this the game's got a stand system
these circle these here so we got the
stances top middle and bottom stance
and if you're attacking you want to be
in a different stance your opponent if
you are defending you want to try and
match it because that's how you block
okay okay and the diff
and the key for that is if you are
matching stance your resolve goes down
way slower really yeah and if you are
out of stance you lose resolve quicker
and that's when your opponent can hit a
killing blower got you okay so basically
the
is it almost like a rock paper scissors
at the stances that's not exactly okay
because you can carry from any stance
you get the timing right it doesn't
matter what stance you're in you parry
you're safe right but you said the
disadvantage is if the stances are
matched in the way are unmatched
unmatched
cool so we're going to get some more
customization on it now one thing i like
to say off the bat the game looks
absolutely beautiful yeah what engine is
that about a blade using a diaper the
blade is running on unreal 4. i've
looked at unreal five but you know the
game's coming out this year and it's
really you know
at this stage that would be really
disruptive as much as much as it would
look you know
even better but we're really pleased
with how it looks already it looks
absolutely phenomenal how many
characters are we looking at as far as
dive by the blade are there gonna be
more characters we're looking at six
characters um but again the weapons are
what's important right and we're looking
at five weapons with a bunch of uh
different moves different combos
all fully performance captured by
martial artists
oh so we've taken it to the essex we
have some real martial artists [ __ ]
yeah so we like that the lords are about
that that's a good job that's a good job
okay and then also from a maybe from a
narrative standpoint is there going to
be a story component yeah there's going
to be a story for sure
um it's going to be you know roughly
about two hours long so nothing too
extensive but it's going to tell you the
story of yoshi here
going through a samurai point feudal
japan
and now yoshi will be considered like
the main protagonist for the most part
you'll certainly be the main character
he's a protagonist that's up to you
enough now as far as development how
long has david have played we got the
lords in the building we got lord king
lord saul they're about to get it on
right now put it through its faces but
as far as development how long has it
been to go it's been in development for
sort of three or four years now yeah but
as a i work on the publishing side we
came on board last year nice nice
exciting cool man so we got another
character tell me about this character
here uh this is ocho uh ciao cho um she
is
um another member of the resistance
in the single player campaign but you
will meet her and you'll understand a
bit more of her backstory one thing i
got to give you credit i feel like
again the lords come from the fighting
game genre and we almost feel like it's
such a fun but yet dying breed what
inspired you to make a fighting game in
this day and age yeah so i mean
a lot of people feel like video games
are getting saturated but the fighting
game genre
there's not really that many coming out
there's a lot of indie games coming out
there's not too many uh fighting games
that aren't coming from the established
brands
right so
there's some there's some that break out
and they're real inspirations
but really it's just you know it's the
it's the information to make something
unique that is so cool
we're glad to keep the genre alive thank
you thank you
we're glad that you're here to champion
it as well that's what we're here for so
again getting the fight and getting it
right now they figure it out this is
king versus solve getting it on trying
to figure out this they're very tactical
right now no one's making a move i think
they get i think they're getting lessons
from uh from our community manager over
there awesome now as far as stages and
stuff like that i'm seeing a lot like
the camera panic now do we have full
three-dimensional movement are we
staying on this plane uh so you'll have
full three-dimensional movement it's not
like back and forth like some fighting
games will be able to move around your
opponent
now as far as staging is concerned we
love this background love this aesthetic
how many stages are there i was sort of
looking at 15 to 20.
so this this one's taken actually
directly from the single player campaign
so there'll be some stages that are
bespoke and some stages that you will
you will play as a single player but
it'll also be an option to play in the
multiplayer too awesome awesome i love
it what i'm saying now i'm also noticing
we're having these arrows and the
circles on the characters yeah what does
that represent so the arrows represent
your stance so top middle and bottom got
it the circles there if you notice as
they attack it lights up yes that is the
window for you to execute the next stage
of your combo got it
i'm sorry
it's just a bit of visual communication
to help people understand the timings um
to master those combos got it now will
we decide whether we'll keep those in
for the full game
whether we might turn it off for
competition so that people really have
to master the visual
language of the game
um but for now on the show floor getting
people to understand the game quickly is
perfect totally understand because again
you can kind of get the newer player to
understand the basic mechanics but like
you said from a competitive standpoint
king
this is this is bloviating after victory
continue
this thing also i'm going to say from an
inspiration standpoint the vibes it
gives me obviously traditional fighter
but getting like bushido
there's definitely some inspiration
there for sure but what we're looking to
do is evolve it update it and really
create something new
um we're hoping it's going to scratch
that it's for a lot of people there's
not been a sheet of ap years yes um but
you know it's not a clone it's
utterly
now good as far as platforms what are we
looking at as far as dive by the blades
now we're looking at pc and consoles
online
and they'll be it'll be fully cosplay as
well oh nice really cool really cool and
like i said this thing
it's a throwback to a hair as far as i'm
concerned yeah sure have you ever seen
it it's definitely got that throwback
vibe but hopefully it's modern enough
that it feels fast and snappy yes and in
the engine it looks phenomenal yeah yeah
okay so we have two more we've got one
more battle between king and saul here
we go iron lord versus iron lord
let's get it
no one wants to make a move i'm almost
there so very tactical in the beginning
okay
so that's how you can see that 360
movement worked in the in yoshi's favor
yeah he was able to dodge away from the
plane of the attack okay
and then you know maybe with a bit more
practice either he can retoss
you know either get a killing blowing or
do some real damage to that result
that's what i was going to ask you so
for us i know the
counter so the report is explain that
mechanic
so it's not an exact mechanic there's no
like exact request it's all about your
timing and understanding the standard
system gadget so your response you're
repost
yeah it's basically have you found the
correct opening
[Applause]
body
very nasty with the blade
clearly we know who king is
kick is where they work right now
hopefully some get it together so i'll
always take these traditional characters
that's what i love though
hey hey stop
right there whether he meant it or not
that was a combo
so
um yoshi had full resolve but because
king pulled up in a sequence two combat
he went straight through it wow and it's
a one-hit kill if you get that right
that's a hitter yeah yeah yeah
okay right this is that time he pulled
up a combo and he actually got the parry
right so he staggered him backwards and
again
maybe a little bit better
he could have been on the front foot you
can say we're not that good let's go
well you know it's it's supposed to be
skilled
yeah yeah
okay then maybe with a bit more time
um you get that right
open them up right now
okay come on
don't try and think very aggressive
see the mistake he's making here
they're not matching stances or at least
they weren't
what was your feel real quick like what
was your feeling of the game overall you
know i love pairing and i couldn't
the pairing
has to do with sort of like the stance
the stance yeah right so if you're not
finished into the stance compared
essentially the block isn't gonna work
very well either like you're gonna get
hit your sound is gonna go down quickly
yeah but i do i love the fact that it
has it has the
kind of the flash
the whole calendar with the groundedness
okay
let's get it
you're ready
there we go
king has been dominant this is the death
let's go oh it can't beat this death we
never gonna hit everything
the king party to death it's all owned
don't get that
let's see let's see
look it up
let's go
okay king versus the dev y'all became
the body of everybody this damn
it's real serious with it
very tactical right now
lot of nails
okay very aggressive very aggressive
triggers but he's repulsed his results
it's shanky
although he's
down we're working it out
a lot of strategy the massive look at
charlie you got to pay attention to the
stances
oh quick breaking defense keep chopping
down that tree
they're taking the building
king said i'm going to beat this down
genuinely slightly nervous
i gotta get cake credit here in the mix
but dad waiting for his opening
so listen
right before he killed me
oh yeah
oh
wow
he's just waiting
are you ready for that open that's all
he goes i know
that was pretty low
oh god
you know what he actually i'm not
getting my parry right thank you
i am not getting it right here we go
birds could bleed
i see brooklyn even guys can flee even
dance completely
you might not be able to release this
game it can't beat you
king
right now
absolutely phenomenal i love podcast
approved
if you had us married i was i was
slightly worried
about my deaf team if he would have beat
you oh he would have to put king in the
game as dlc
i can't give my dead team that type of
work
we love it again for the people if they
want to support down by the blade where
can they find it where can they go it's
up on
steam and epic to wishlist now
but it'll be available on consoles that
launch too so keep an eye out absolutely
phenomenal a pleasure down by the blade
i love broadcast approved go check it
out
[Music]
you